good morning Hank it's Tuesday November
6 2012 you cannot title a video spicy
summer camp story and then have it be
about actual spices that's just false
advertising by the way Hank this is
Susan she's my zit so today I'm gonna
tell an actual spicy summer camp story
complete with frenching which is what we
called kissing with tongue so I'm just
as a preface when I was young I was told
that the difference between kissing like
your friend and kissing someone you were
romantically involved with was the
tongue and then I came to the natural
conclusion that the more tongue you use
the more closely romantically linked you
were to the person you were licking as
you can imagine this may be a great
kisser wait it's Tuesday November 6 2012
it's Election Day okay I'm gonna get
back to the story but first a three-part
guide and how to vote step 1 wake up at
6:20 two in the morning overwhelmed with
anxiety done step two make sure you've
done your research there's a link in the
doobly-doo where you can find your
polling place and also all the elections
in your area
most people know who they want to vote
for for like Senator and president but
have you done your school board research
the school board election is arguably
the most important one of all because
they will decide the central issue of
our time
should my novel Looking for Alaska be
banned from high school classrooms it's
the only election where I'm truly a
one-issue voter I'm like what is your
stance on banning my book step 3 once
you've woken up at 622 in the morning
paralyzed with anxiety and done your
research it's time to go vote
okay so I've arrived at the polling
station to have my little notes to help
me remember who I want to vote for and
I'm here with the Yeti not pictured how
do you feel about voting you know ladies
couldn't vote until quite recently we
didn't trust you with it okay we did it
I vote I count okay that was fun back to
the Frenchy but first please vote I
speak to you as a former non-voter
please vote you will never regret it
okay so 49 weeks out of the year I was a
massive nerd with cooties and frenching
me was seen as like a social catastrophe
but then three weeks a year I would go
to summer camp and suddenly I was in the
middle I wasn't like hot or anything but
I was in the middle and being in the
middle sometimes people want to be your
girlfriend and they will even maybe want
to French you French you French with you
friendship at you I don't know with me
as an adolescent it was more of a French
act right okay so not to brag but over
eight years of summer camp Hank I kissed
six girls all of them frame
not the girls to kissing and as you can
imagine since I was someone who wasn't
frenching 49 weeks a year and also
believed that the way to say I like you
was to maximize face licking I was
really bad at kissing I was like a cat
trying to clean the face of my beloved
and I should add that I also did not
enjoy these kisses but I thought they
were what you were supposed to do no one
ever told me that I was bad until one
day I'm at summer camp it's the last
night of summer camp I'm like 14 years
old I think I was actually older than
that I don't want to tell you how old I
actually was but I'm at a square dance
and I'm kissing my girlfriend of like
three days and a friend comes up to me
and pulls me aside and he said you're
joking right and I was like joking about
what having a beautiful girlfriend and
he was like no you're joking with that
terrible weird thing that you're doing
that you think is kissing and then I
went over to my girlfriend of like three
days and I was like am i a really
terrible kisser
and she said yes and then I said well
how can I be better and she showed me
and suddenly kissing got awesome so Hank
the moral of my spicy summer camp story
is vote Hank I'll see you tomorrow